[Music]
and body-fluid swap news
submitted by fantasy football yes
I'm the only one that's looser we're
gonna watch a corpse chemistry
transplanting poop can be beneficial but
swapping vaginal fluids may be even
better geo we've been doing that with
transplanting poop can be beneficial
yeah like you take my poop and put in
your body your matter into so we've
never done we have talked about this is
what I mean we've done this is the gut
by old bio like [ __ ] probiotics or
something the probiotics some people
when they found out that like let's say
I have a probiotic or something that
like let's say TIFF doesn't have right
oh you'd give her yours yeah yeah so
like like they literally like implant
the [ __ ] in her yeah it's your like
implanting you're [ __ ] me or they
take a poop capsule yeah and then that's
how they have it in the body
ya know you put it through your mouth
yeah I'd rather just put it in my
[ __ ] and they found out like all
kinds of dope [ __ ] like you can speed up
a person's metabolism or like whatever
and yeah it's crazy
some people can't produce poop
genetically and so they have to get a
poop transplant and then now it's the
exchange of flora it's good I wouldn't
if girls are starting to scissor now
more they're likely to [ __ ] give you
my [ __ ] juices my ph balance is off
let's do it Joe it has helped really
it's not like this you know it's a
rocking motion thank you Joe knows
better than I knew sorry
it's more like this no Gilbert knows I
think out of all of you I would probably
want Bart's poo come on it's not his
[ __ ] doesn't though remember think about
the protein powder in there bro look
it's like that he creates [ __ ]
masterful shits shits that only a mother
could love
yeah all right I'm just saying even when
he shits you're like I'm so proud of
them I am I know it's cute I think like
this [ __ ] like that's pretty funny no no
you guys we're on two different
wavelengths for a second like this we
good
I'm not there yet but once he starts
being a [ __ ] I will
laughing but like your did call it was
stupid okay wow that's a horrible TI
dico
cover your ears dude I could let Benham
alright so this is called the food
transplants they're called fecal micro
micro bio micro Brio microbiota
microbiota microbiota know what to
school there yeah yeah stuff that
transplants or FM t book my titties oh
yeah that's type so there see the now
they're looking into researchers at John
Hopkins are looking into vaginal
microbiota transplant sore VMT and so
they're saying that these are 2 40
doctors they just want to watch one look
I can't that's the motivation how can we
get more [ __ ] guys we test studies are
ladies go ahead how did they even come
up with this [ __ ]
no because of the fecal microbiota
transplant is it for the pH balance and
[ __ ] cuz some women they always be
getting [ __ ] like that could be part
of it
baby Easton maybe they proud to
yesterday they see me you stay in my pH
levels are matching that girl over there
oh you actually know the word yeah it's
good song got a lot of tight I only know
the chorus part or that part phase they
see me rollin they hatin that's it I
can't understand the rest of it I know I
am your mother trust me I'm likin and
not zi8 more and Ickes like shut the
[ __ ] up why do they have to see it that
way where no one understands it's too
fast right in right look if she's thin
she's really riding dirty that's true
actually I mean you're dirty if you're
Houston easton if you have a yeast
infection isn't that dirty I don't think
so Jamie I mean
sorry about talking about your yeast
infection unit definitely not but if I
did have what I would not be it just
means you need a transplant yeah but you
see I guess that that means you got a
scissor a girl with hot with a nice pH
balance that's true yeah that's what
we've learned so they're saying here
it's called bacterial vaginosis
your words are telling you this
bacterial vaginosis this article's just
a [ __ ] what if only the [ __ ] relation
Steve I can never pronounce it so this
is linked to a range of problems
including increased risk of urinary
tract infections greater susceptibility
to getting and spreading sexually
transmitted infections issues with
infertility and preterm birth and so
they're saying that bacterial vaginosis
is estimated to affect around 30% of us
women aged 14 to 49 according to CDC
what's wrong with their [ __ ] she just
explained it so you sound like a pig
what's wrong with her [ __ ] not me like
my phone is pushing ahead gets them
there what's the motivation for the
yeast interviews right now that's a good
question they have they don't have a
dominant bacteria called lactobacillus
they got a weak ass [ __ ] mm-hmm you
know lactobacillus - it's in the Yakko
Yakko they need is [ __ ] spread their
[ __ ] lips and pour Yakult in that [ __ ]
what is he uncle yeah jinx with the old
a really good that's an actual Asian
thing sorry
dirty Yakult yeah yes the first ever
heard of that was confused
what's Yakult with those glasses it's
more official yeah so it's like do play
but not in a tube but it's a drinkable
it's like liquid you'll play like
go-gurt yeah more than
yeah more liquidy than yogurt drink like
a straight-up melted yo it's like drink
like a yoo-hoo viscosity yeah and that's
quick very nice but it's like thank you
now you have actually described
something Asian to me that I did not
know and actually know we used to drink
it it's a huge thing in Mexican it's a
white thing that's all I do
hey have you [ __ ] you guy have you tried
yeah cold soda they mix don't take my
white culture for me
beautiful white culture we're talking
about barbecue you mix it people in
Southeast Asia they do it they get the
they get Yakko and then they get like
club soda or whatever and they [ __ ]
mix it oh yeah it's like a [ __ ]
Italian soda Cal piss the [ __ ] yeah
the yogurt drink no Kappa CLP is you
know that's the Japanese brand it's
called cat no that's Cal Pecos for
America because in Japan it's called Cal
piss CLP is I think God they changed it
yeah yeah yeah that's why for here they
call it cow Pico Italians get pissed if
people drink their sodas in there not a
time I'm kind of Italian so I've never
heard any flack about it but you can't
officially state it if you don't have
the full percentage what's the
percentage like 100 [ __ ]
only Danny DeVito can speak I won't
speak on or Mario from the Mario
Brothers yeah yeah he's the best
mr. Mario talk about warrior oh oh yeah
we got a noun but anyway we're talking
about the EMTs that scissoring just say
it the right way no because that's not
what it is though definitely want it to
be about so are they started getting a
syringe and soak it like getting a [ __ ]
juice out of one girl and then like puts
pushing it into another [ __ ] like no
there's so scientific I'm taking [ __ ]
one juice I think there's a [ __ ] - is
this [ __ ] - a boozy warm we lost [ __ ]
- I guess I'm gonna have to do it again
because we're [ __ ] - when it's a boozy
one and that was the opposite
there you go that's what they did not
appeal cuz Ken if [ __ ] two gets back
into [ __ ] one does that mean that she
affects it who's the bad [ __ ] first so
poop to see one is the good [ __ ] the
Kikuchi two is the weak [ __ ] right so
they're trying to soak up the juices
from [ __ ] one you guys smell like a
bunch of virgins and put it into situ so
then they could they could make her a
strong [ __ ] yeah but then what if the
opposite happens and in the implant the
weak into the strong [ __ ] is invincible
it is because it's strong does so you
put the weak bacteria into the habit
stays strong maybe yeah [ __ ] are
pretty strong cuz they can take the
pounding oh yeah does it who bar pounds
pretty hard to they do talk about women
who have sex with women and that they
vaginal microbiota transfers are pause
because they're scissors but they still
need to be proven and refined in
clinicals refine if they're doing over
and over over it's not clinically as I
watch this the question is no this is
not horny at all but the question is if
they're not wet how do the scientists
get them wet you don't have to be wet
finally was able to pull up a photo yeah
cool that's yep oh you never seen that
I've never seen them yeah that's white
culture bro you never been to lavon's
that's asian things i never see them if
they have that aroused no no they have
that they have it every girl's also born
yesterday that is next to the American
flag at Ralph's it is no way that is by
the waters and all the different Asian
sauces yeah that's in the sriracha
that's mix it a hanging ducks yeah well
they don't have that in my rolls not my
rouse yeah that's that's like the og
probiotic [ __ ] like before everyone got
on the probiotic craze
they've been around for like since like
that wait so now that work for guys like
guys touching dicks or something you
just trying to find a reason to [ __ ]
sword fight aren't you I just want to
make sure I might get healthier you know
you need a switch dick fluid we don't
have dick biomes know we would you
it's like docking but you would like
come at the same time so weak guy in a
strong guy come at the same time boom
connect like that
switch but what's the power that they
get for the week Kyle okay Bart stop
asking [ __ ] questions a week I have
to eat it makes me strong that's a
culture made you tall too you guys tell
her from Bart's fast suck on Bart's comp
you will get taller just like that do
that whatever you do we think you will
get taller
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]